hello we are live stormy and welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
um
wow okay right I'm gonna tell you
straight away
I'm a bit drunk
so because I the reason why we're late
today is because I was watching my team
Manchester United
destroy Arsenal who were top of the
league
um
but anyway
let's go let's just see what happens
foreign
[Music]
how are you feeling mate well I'm still
covered positive but my coughing gets a
little bit less less everything and I'm
going to cough all over your show
so oh wow Kleenex
no spray
um Coke
really
very good well as long as you are well
enough we're happy all right so
today we're going to have a little bit
of chat about the rings of power and
we're going to throw a little little bit
of House of the Dragon in just you know
like have that little bit of a curveball
but um
you've obviously seen the two opening
episodes
yes sir good that's a good start
so just generally what did you think
generally we'll get into the minutia of
it but what did you think
whatever I watched them both twice
it was amazing to me
how well they did
in terms of Storytelling with all the
restrictions the Tolkien estate has on
Amazon Studios
I mean
you know they are an Amazon Studios
can't use silmaralian they can't use
this or they can't use certainly can't
use these fellowships
you know in the talking State more or
less had
I guess Final Cut on what was
appropriate they can't untananize
anything they have final word on
everything yeah
you know 400 million dollars mate
doesn't buy you what it used to
um
it's like here's 400 million dollars and
you'll do is you're told yes and Amazon
were like okay
whatever it takes to get this show made
we'll do whatever
but I absolutely love it
very well done
acting was incredible
we'll get the haters out of the way
shall we just a few minutes let's get
the haters out the way
right so
um I'll talk to you a bit about I've
watched a bunch of videos from proper
Tolkien fans that have really torn this
apart so I'm really positive some really
negative I'll talk about the positive
ones a bit let's get the negative [ __ ]
out of the way they have a lot of videos
have jumped on
I I've said a lot of these videos have a
massive agenda right because they've
been saying that this show is going to
be a pile of [ __ ] for six months and now
they've watched it they're like no
it's actually quite good but they can't
say it's quite good
so what they've said is it's boring
and I I think they've got a point to to
a line it was a bit it's a bit slow
right
um not a lot happens in the first
episode of action
but
but that's like every TV show ever
you've got a lot of like story to tell
there's a lot to set up there's a lot to
there's a lot of characters to introduce
and the second episode I thought really
cracked on I thought there was a lot
more going on in the second episode
but that's what they said all the videos
have gone uh uh you know all that [ __ ]
about woke we said don't worry about
that
um it's boring instead
uh there's a lot of people talked about
the billion dollars which is also not
quite true really I mean don't get me
wrong they've spent a lot of money on
this show but they haven't really spent
a billion dollars on the first series
they've spent a billion dollars on Five
Seasons so far that a lot of the money
they've spent is will trickle through
the whole project sort of thing
um and they've talked an awful lot about
why they're Hobbits in this
there shouldn't be Hobbits and that goes
well there aren't they're half foots and
they go oh yeah yeah but those are still
Hobbits they're not
so
calm down
um Yusuf has said that he didn't like it
that's okay
I don't mind if you don't like it I do
mind if you decided six months ago that
you're not gonna like it that kind of
pisses me off right really I mean it
does
if there's anything that proves
you don't like it
100 agenda yeah I would understand
the other big Point okay
right so the other big point a lot of
the videos have been throwing out oh
he's got a book oh he's going to read to
us oh crap
um so the other big point a lot of these
videos have made is on the Rotten
Tomatoes score of 36 on the audience
um appreciation so the critics have
scored it like 95
but the things
a lot of channels have thrown that out
there but with even just a little bit of
research you can find out that Rotten
Tomatoes actually had to freeze the um
the ratings
because they had so many Bots coming in
so basically it was a really loud
minority vote in thousands and thousands
of times zero
and so they actually had to freeze a
load accounts and they've had to freeze
the um the rating thing so what I
thought I would do
is I would put a um
a a thing on my channel and I would ask
the subscribers the lovely lovely
subscribers what they thought and they
just rated it one to five and they'll
give me a second to get there because I
want to do it live
so one to five what did you think I
rated as a four I thought it was a
little bit slow
but understandably slow all right uh
right so one hate it
14. I think that's fair enough for any
show
um two twenty percent three it was okay
it's got potential was thirty percent
twenty seven percent
five out of five absolutely loved it 18
so I would argue that there what's that
I'll do that math quickly 49 over 60 of
this either thought it was it's got
potential and it's it's absolutely fine
it's okay got potential or absolutely
loved it only 14 actually said they hate
it but you look at the YouTube videos
you think
do you think it was the worst show ever
made and that that kind of pisses me off
these kind of people with agendas you
just want to go you know
[ __ ] off
um OMG just mentioned that the sound
isn't great
um I think that that's you stormy but
you you're on your you're on your laptop
today aren't you so it's not I apologize
my laptop I'm in a very echoey room
and you're really normal computer
because I can't get them a normal house
because I've got coven I don't want to
spread it all over carnations
so it's either I'm sorry guys but it's
either you just listening to me on my
own or a little bit of crappy sound but
we'll do our best and I can't talk on my
own for now
well 500 Millions bought this other than
visuals yeah well the visuals are
Cinema standard absolutely
yeah
but very run in the middle fantasy I
just think it needs to turn but I tell
you one question we'll ask a question a
bit later on because there's another
fantasy TV show at the moment with
swords and dragons and things called
House of the Dragon that's also two or
three episodes in
so maybe we'll compare the two a little
later
but for now
generally you liked it you thought it
was good I like the
um you know I was going I saw
um I saw the episodes on Thursday when
they first dropped here
U.S and I said well you know let me go
and uh
like it
and I couldn't
you know then I went to IMDb and I said
well you know let me go comment
12 hours and there was Zero reviews and
it had a one score with zero reviews
yeah and since then IMDb has opened up
their polling and
if you look at the rankings you know
right now it gets it's uh at six point
seven is the app is what it ranks on
IMDb if you look at the weighted score
yeah um 33 of the audience gave it a 10
another 10 percent gave it another 10
percent gave it a name another five
percent gave it you know a five
and it says 33 43 53. so more than 60 of
the
uh of the uh viewers
rated it you know seven or five
but then the ones the people that rated
it as a one is 25 percent
there's a lot of people that wanted to
hate this show
not everyone's going to like the show
but these people have been playing know
exactly what Tolkien what I want there's
this one it is a British guy to be fair
so I'm going to apologize about in my
entire nation but there's this one guy
who's been doing videos about
um hating this this for months and
months and he is double down he says
this is the worst and he keeps saying
about oh these critics say [ __ ] as well
and he dug out one or two critics that
hated it most the critics have said they
absolutely love it but the storyline in
the first couple of episodes is a bit
stunted and it's a bit
it's a bit um it's a bit difficult
because there's lots and lots of
characters to you know introduce but
it's it's one of the most visually
beautiful things we've ever had on
television and which is a hundred
percent true
um you can see a couple hundred million
dollars man yeah yeah another thing I'd
like
[Music]
where's all these black people coming
from
where's all these dark characters coming
from and this is the Tolkien dictionary
first published in 19
79 I think it was yes 1979 Oculus
publishers
here's the definition of Harford
most numerous and typical of The Hobbit
strains were those who were named the
Harford
they were the smallest of the halflings
and their skin and hair were nut browned
the Harford were the first of The Hobbit
people to leave the veils of into him
and cross over the Misty Mountains into
era
the migration was the year of the 10th
excuse me 1050 of the third age they
were the friendliest with the drawers
they loved their hillsides and Highlands
and the whole dwelling to them was a joy
so they um they were migrating they've
always been migrating they stopped
migrating sometime in the urban mid
third a day so right there it is
they even mentioned nuts in the season
in the second episode they even
mentioned there as soon as they saw the
meter right they were like let's break
camping let's get out of here sort of
thing and they're like no no we're safer
in the camp so they show that they're a
migratory even though well I think
so on the positive I watched a couple of
videos from people that really know
about Lord of the Rings as as you do
um because I I don't
um I'm I'm one of the Casual viewers and
we'll talk about that a little bit more
in a bit but I'm one of more casual
views so
um the amount of detail they put in but
like you mentioned earlier the amount of
stuff they've had to skirt around
because they don't have the rights
they're saying there's a couple of
battles that are mentioned in the first
couple of minutes they can't name them
because they don't have the rights to
them and that's pissed off the tokenists
but I'm like all the people have decided
they hate this show Amazon don't have a
choice on that they go in as far as they
can without getting sued
which they really don't want to do right
um they are kind of restricted and they
do have a lot of material to draw on and
just from the first two episodes I've
seen
threads
of
and suggestions of
um other works from
the world of Lord of the Rings some of
it comes from the treason of Isengard
yeah are on defeated
the war of the Ring
the shaping of Middle Earth
relay is a barrel yeah
the Wall Street
Maryland and Lutheran
book of lost Tales uh part two and part
one or Goss ring
uh children are killing yep there's a
little bit of that in there and there's
a whole bunch of them
Earth and then there's the oh they're
going to get to this one or of the
jewels but most of it comes from
unfinished tails
me and I
you know ring.net Discord are you really
um broke down where a lot of his
material is coming from and where the
stories could possibly go
and yeah they don't they can't use the
Hobbit can't use any of the Lord of the
Rings books can't use the sill morality
that seems to be a big problem
they can draw
now one thing I saw that was not canon
absolutely made up
there was
the uh I forget the actor's name that he
was
oh yeah Charlie Baker's playing Halbert
he was the god dude on the boat
oh yes I guess we should say there's
gonna be spoilers in this but there will
be supporters if you haven't seen it
you're one of the 25 million people
didn't watch it immediately but this but
this honestly this is Bond Amazon
regretting making it because it's bombed
so badly oh yeah billion people the
biggest Premiere they've ever had but
anyway
but habern was is a new character that's
okay
he maybe
found out he'd be the son of another
character
but you know that what that is mentioned
in like similar alien or something let
me remind you that halbron
whoever this guy is has approval from
the tokens test for being non-10 or new
can
and uh so we just don't but there are
several things several popular must be
like a dozen people that he could be the
son of or related to or something that's
not absolutely named but it is that
person we just don't know you it's like
the stranger that came in the fireball
of the Earth yeah he's one of the blue
Wizards who's never been named
by Tolkien anywhere or he could be a
balrog
one of those
demons you just don't know yeah so
there's lots we just don't know but
there's lots of material
that
is yet to be revealed and remember
Amazon has what 48 more hours to tell
this story oh yeah
we got a while to go yeah the the one
thing I'd say so the people also need to
remember is this is a new story set six
thousand years before the Lord of the
Rings it is based on Tolkien and that
seems to be the big argument a lot of
people have and it was well Tolkien will
be rolling in his grave and I'm like
there's a lot of people that seem to
know exactly what Tolkien would want and
what he wouldn't want
I mean the family they're the people
have actually got an invested interest
in the talking name they're more than
happy
um I know obviously they got 400 million
dollars out of this
which that would make me very happy too
but I mean they're not poor people
anyway because I mean they made quite a
woman but also they went out of their
way to make sure they kept control of
lots of things and when the story said
well you know we would quite like some
Wizards in this they went well you can't
because they didn't exist in the first
stage so you can't have them tough
and you know the film next one wizard
good one they're like now
in the background no
this is kind of rumored to be in the
second day
this is supposed to be the uh it starts
in the first doesn't it wanders into the
second but I mean the family from what I
read said you can't have him so you
can't have it yeah I mean you know yeah
I mean yeah that is true it's like uh a
Fellowship of the Ring started kind of
in the tail end of the first stage and
you know when
for the secondary twin uh
Sauron lost the ring lost his finger
the hand of the king during that battle
and but yeah so but that was all Prelude
to photo or whatever yeah so there's
lots of Prelude there too early right I
mean I mean you know they show the two
trees of Valor which I mean day one man
you know
so I I tell you what the first couple of
bits I loved from the first episode
Elsa dicks
and when they particularly young elves
um but from again what I've read is
that's what's in all the material that
they are dicks and they're painting
they're very arrogant very up themselves
and it was after several severe Wars and
the the race got a lot older that they
mellowed by the third age and but you
know the one bit I watched the first bit
you know he um I don't know the
character's name sorry but he he leans
into galadria and he says why do boats
float and rock sink and I went oh I know
this one it's mass and density and then
he went oh it's because of the light and
the dark and the thing and then they're
going no no it's the mass and the
density thing
leans in and whispered you don't always
know until you touch the light
from the density thing
I I I I I might have missed a big chunk
of the first vid episode because I was
just there going I'm sure it's [ __ ]
mass and density
um
but I I did like that and to be honest
I I just I I loved it I I loved I loved
the character the glad you're character
because I can see how it ends up and I'd
love to for you to give us a bit of a
run down as a glad you're a character in
a second for the more casual View and
because obviously I know her from the
film but it's only very brief but I I
understand I don't really I did read the
books when I was a kid but I don't
really remember
um but her Obsession some people have
actually dared to come out and call her
a Mary Sue
um they're just like oh just she's
awesome and running around and all the
men uh are making look stupid and I'm
like
she's obsessed
that's the point
look how good she is to climbing
mountains
well more about a little bit before we
get to the Mary Sue time
um the elves have always been at war
with somebody I mean there hasn't been
really a big long huge strength of Peace
in elvendom I mean hell they're always
making weapons I mean even in season two
they're wanting you know want to build
that
in episode two they're wanting to build
this new uh Forge to make nice things
[Music]
that sound is pretty bad dammit a second
you might want to start that again that
was I don't know what's going on there
but it's a lot of scratchy noises
and up until the third age they were
mostly a warlike race
I mean and even in the uh in the Peter
Jackson films you know we see scene
after scene of Fallen elf you know in
the swamps going into Moria you know
photo does a header right into
partially preserved dead elf bodies War
um
I mean you know the the
um
in the landscape the Middle Earth is
coming
saturated with mass Graves of elk so
they've always been you know a whirlwind
yeah
uh culture and we've always tried to be
on a side of life but you know of course
there's a lot of darkness and
talking about
yeah
they definitely like a rumble
but the reason
uh or Galadriel
I mean she was the by the time we get to
the Lord The Return of the King
um the last elf that's ever seen between
the light of the Trees of Valor
I mean it was such a long time ago and
she's one of those things she's probably
one of the oldest elves Alive by the
time we get to uh to return the king I
think she's actually probably older
Yeah by several thousand years
so you know she was she's
throughout the book she's always had you
know
swords and uh armor and
you know and she was very what we see in
The Hobbit a little bit in Lord of the
Rings she was she really didn't use a
sword as much as a as over her life she
honed her magical skills
you know when we're trying to see in The
Hobbit where she uses some dark magic
skills so she kind of moved away from
you know uh Elven rot armor and swords
to something a little bit more creepy in
the photos
okay so what sort of weapons do you mean
what you mean more magical weapons or
something what well I mean you know it
uh this was in a Battle of the Five
Armies I think it was she turns into the
dark Galadriel she you know exists
almost a black and white ghostly
Apparition of galadriel's spirit as she
does battle with the Necromancer
okay he's always had a battle going on
with
that's not it's an obsession and that's
the whole point of which is that one is
this was like oh she climbs the
mountains so quickly she does this this
and this and I'm like yes because she is
I know beyond obsessed though as well
the other elves that started after
several decades they're starting to
doubt it where she is just
fixated on Pharaoh
um and even when they get to the final
that that final castle that final
Outpost is supposed to be necessary that
we're not supposed to go any further
than this and that she still wants to
and everyone else is like ah you know
come on let's not be too silly
um one thing you know climbing up the
mountain so quickly
the athleticism that's part of the lore
of elves in uh tolkien's works is they
are very
uh adapt at moving quickly through
natural landscapes if you like uh during
Fellowship of the Ring when they were
going on their way to Moria and sauroman
sent this whole storm toward the
mountain and all this snow comes and
traps everybody if you look Legolas is
still walking on top of the snow
everybody else is buried underneath it
he can walk on the snow without leaving
tracks Lots most people didn't pick that
up
swimming through the Sun during sea very
quickly uh
other elves you know like climbing up
the mountain quite readily and
uh
a lot of things that you see Legolas do
and Lord of the Rings was kind of you
know trippy
yeah but like this is a lie or two
oh bless him I'm just so sick so thank
you so much for still coming on evening
I mean it was perfect for me so
um obviously I've watched The House of
the Dragon yes
what do you think it has to drag in the
first two corpse episodes of that
because I mean that's a big that's got
big shoes to fill in itself
yeah I didn't know Matt Smith could be
so creepy he's good it's unsettling man
I mean I see him mostly As
you know uh was it prince it's Dr Who
yeah but you know he's yelling in the
Crown Prince
oh he was uh I never actually watched it
but he was
right and he was kind of
you know Prince Charles and he's of
course then he was Doctor Who there for
a while but then
God I mean in his portrayal
we saw him being a little bit naughty in
The Terminator movie Losing well really
kind of creepy in that but that was a
terrible movie
um but he was good but now he's just a
bloody good actor at the end of the day
and
I was you know I've only seen the first
episode of
um House of dragon I would say his
performance carried it though just the
first episode was even better holy [ __ ]
yeah it's more he's not in the second
episode but it's building up towards the
wall
that is obviously going to happen
um to me if I had to pick if you said to
me right you can only watch one you can
only watch
thanks for the dragon or ring of power
I'd be like hash the dragon you wouldn't
even have to I wouldn't even end the
question I think most of the Dragon is
so much more entertaining
um and don't get me wrong there are
problems with it
um it's only supposed to be I think it's
300 years before Game of Thrones
something like that it's not that long
before Game of Thrones but the dragons
are still pretty big and they're
supposed to like be the size of kittens
by the end of like when the Mad King is
there so they must get little or really
quickly
um so I think they've they've messed
that up a little bit
um but other than that little fupa
um
oh it's just it's just good I mean the
way they've set it up it's it's still
very much feels like Game of Thrones and
they haven't sort of um they're not of
their own ass or anything which are a
lot of TV shows after the success Game
of Thrones has had they might go well we
have to be a bit more serious now
they've gone no no we've got a style
let's stick to it
they've got brilliant actors again I
don't think there's any British actors
left that haven't appeared in either
Game of Thrones or how so I'm pretty
sure I appeared in an episode of Game of
Thrones
um as the only British person
it's 200 years Peter
I couldn't remember
look in between but yeah everybody's in
it
um if if you actually have every British
report between Game of Thrones and Harry
Potter they're all in it there aren't
any left there's none
in the
the people's trailing behind they're all
in Downton Abbey
yeah
that's what they did at the weekend
um
what would you think that if I talk if I
said to you now you are only allowed to
watch one or the other
day
uh you know it's gonna be having
reasons I mean I you know uh
Blood series on my Kindle
these aren't actually
[Music]
nothing's concerning Thompkins life his
Christmas Tales you know and then
actually the Lord of the Rings books and
the Heart
I mean
you need to get out more
let's go get rid of this I am so leaving
this out
I say I think you had long periods of
time when you were in school that you
didn't have a girlfriend
in fourth grade
somebody more Hometown spray painted
Frodo lives on the local
and so I asked the librarian what was
that all about and she said there's this
well there's this author and he was
still alive
we call it a J.R Tolkien and he wrote
this book called The Harbor you should
start there
I checked it out
I've changed
let's see I watched it when I was a kid
I read him when I was a kid
I remember the cartoon came out and I
loved the cartoon Lord of the Rings they
never quite finished it did they but I
still loved it
um so I I read the books
um and I was alright with them but I
preferred like the um
uh like the Prince Caspian stores can I
maybe I read the Lord of the Rings too
soon because I'd have been about
809 and maybe I just wasn't quite ready
for them but then I read like The Voyage
of the Dawn Treader
Prince Caspian and you know
yeah the Narnia but I love the Narnia
books I was a big the final battle
Voyage of the Dawn tread was always my
favorite but I read those two or three
times
yeah well they've got very similar style
in movies so I completely understand
they'd be good friends yeah uh makes
sense to me so is there anything other
than like one little bit that you said
is there anything from the first two
episodes that you are concerned about
concerned is the pace quick enough for
you is enough going on is there anything
that jumped out you thought that doesn't
quite fit is the style right
well you know there's just nothing that
concerned concerns me I don't have this
concern from Italian I know what it is I
know what the limitations are
yeah I know they're pulling from a dozen
different books and sources from uh
um
I thought you know the the first episode
of uh House of dragons a little bit slow
I went back to walk way back and watched
the first episode of uh Game of Thrones
and it was about the same pace so
there's lots of world we're in an era
where there's lots of World building
here in power of the Rings and a house
um I don't have you know I so far in
House of dragon I don't have my uh my
imp love you know going yet you know I
mean I really love the character
yeah
oh God what a great performance I'm not
there yet I mean Matt Smith really
[ __ ] trips my mind man oh my God I
did not expect that kind of performance
out of here I mean it was really good
but again I've always
I don't want to judge him
the the I don't have any worries really
with either House of dragons or
um
uh
the uh things of power yeah
we'll say the writing or the harfoots in
writing for the dwarves is absolutely
excellent I had to go back and put on
closed captioning just so I can catch
all the quick witty dialogue of the hard
foots
they're always using these car cart
metaphors you know that was just just
genius and you know it's and then the
the the the husband you know during and
his wives
bickering at the table who's just
Excellent Man that's very important
I say as an Englishman it feels very
a very known you know it's like the way
they the way the friends talk to each
other the way the whole speech is the
way any Henry uh the half foot talks and
is you know the accents they use is very
like
yes this this and there are a couple of
Americans I believe that wrote it I'm
sure they're Americans one might be
Canadian I forget
um but it's it's done very well
um the way they've done it is is is is
excellent to be honest
um and yeah I I
like I said I think it's a bit slow but
I was expecting it to be slow but I also
didn't have the expectations and I think
I think that one of the reasons why some
people are very very angry about this
show is the amount of money that Amazon
have spent on it they don't like Amazon
and people almost hate
something because well they like I said
they decided months ago they were going
to hate it yeah um
and you know what there is a lot of
color
in this series compared to the
um books and more in the adverts I
thought and the adverts it did seem like
a lot of the actors were black
yeah but actually watching the series
it's not you know it's not as off as
much as like walking down the street how
many black people I see compared to how
many black people are actually in this
series it's not reflective of my Society
um or reflective of most TV shows
nowadays they're still a lot of white
people in this show I just don't think
people need to be as upset as they are
about that I think
let me do a quick little
it looks like you're of the top cast
we got
um four of the main three of the main
characters that are black
one is I would say it's Indian descent
you know which
you know in the the um the elephant just
got
captured by the Orcs or whatever
you know it's I just don't know to be
honest I don't notice it until somebody
[ __ ] about it you know
um
yeah
you know there was all this uh in
chatter months ago about oh my God
there's black Hobbits
where's my book yeah I mean 1979.
power of eight boys
even the background so I don't give a
crap really because the action they've
got to do it is actually pretty bloody
good
um
yeah I think it's pretty good he he
plays the part that he's supposed to
play really well you know he's he's
quite a Broody character he's in love
with the with them with a human and he
can't have her and other I think he's
you know ignore his skin color
didn't know that
so yeah if it was me
I I I just think there's an awful lot of
people getting very angry about
something about but also they it does
seem to me that they're looking for
things to be angry about now and there
are things that Amazon can't control
like we said that there are things they
don't own the rights to so they've had
to skirt around there's I forget what
the battle's name called but there's
some battle and again another video I
saw I said wow why did they skirt around
that it's one of seminal moments in blah
blah blah whatever history and I'm like
because they don't have the rights to it
they just don't you've got to have a
little bit of your expectations are just
like way up here and also the other
problem is
Amazon cannot make a TV show for the
extreme
fans the fans that know every little
detail about every little character
Amazon can't make a TV show for those
people
nobody you'd have 200 people watching it
yeah you know it's just like they can't
Unfortunately they cannot make a show
for you they have to make a show for me
they have to throw in Easter eggs for
you but I have to understand what the
hell is going on and because this
talking you you know I'll admit token
anything anything written by talking is
a bit on the complex side
I mean even if you look at the Hobbit
you know in the first chapter you've got
what 15 20 main characters that you know
you've got Sauron you've got sour man
you've got you know Gandalf you've got
these drunk dwarves that show up then
you've got
you know Frodo excuse me Bilbo you know
and
um that ice just like first chapter or
two and you got this huge cast and
that's just in The Hobbit
oh and you have to go
so there's there's a lot of care and
it's even The Hobbit was really
complicated I mean
you have to get to it because there's
so many people and so many languages and
so many songs and you know uh but one
thing I will say about to those people
my comment about those people who think
that who are pissed off that
um Amazon paid so much for it and it
costs so much
I am absolutely glad because you know
where that money's going
token mistake it goes back to the author
and
his uh living family
you know and and I'm just not saying
that because I'm a token fan I love it
when writers actually get paid you know
I got a lot of friends that are writers
you know
several genres
and I know the struggles they have from
Publishers and how how hard screwed over
they get from Publishers and for me you
know it's this is at least somebody is
getting tons of money a writer or his
estate is getting money from Corporate
America
has gone on the rights it's like 400
million dollars has gone on the rights
which is by any stretch of the
imagination a crapload of money
um too much money if I'm honest it's too
much money
um but in a world where we spend 100
million dollars on a player nowadays
um you know for my great team we've just
I think the mirror effect on this on
these cameras always get to me I always
go for the wrong tit
um we spent 100 million Euros which is
85 million dollars on a player so I'm
only thinking well 400 million dollars
for a worker
this magnitude maybe is a little more
reasonable
um
turned up on the screen
you know I mean the
I mean I've got one of these big ass 4K
or 8K TVs here
oh my God it is luscious I mean it you
know the the sense of presence the the
sense of the amount of time they took
into creating the costumes
and
um there a lot of that money is up on
the screen yeah
I don't think anybody
in their right mind could say that this
isn't a beautifully made TV show and
that we've never really quite seen
anything like it
um for the scale and not that not in a
movie
and they're going to do 50 hours of this
you know it's not the 12 hours even of
the of the Lord of the Rings or you know
the director's Cuts I think topped out
about 12 hours I think
um and that was enough of a task This Is
50 hours
I know oh my God yeah
so I mean yeah it's it's it's amazing
and um
and yeah it's
I I do have concerns about the amount of
money and effort Amazon are putting into
rings of power because there's a lot of
other projects that aren't going to get
done oh no no joke I mean
yeah yeah I mean I you know you you know
I'm a Stargate fan I am kicking off I
want Stargate to come back and Amazon I
do genuinely think one of the reasons
why they're holding back I mean I don't
know
um and other projects is because I've
invested so much money in the Rings it's
making them just a little bit nervous
about other projects and it's not just
that
stream into we've we've had the Golden
Age of streaming services unfortunately
over the last five years
they're not going to be willing to spend
the money they have done because it's
started to slow down a little bit and
we're all in a cost of living crisis
we're all thinking about us uh costs uh
uh money going out I'm not we're not
going to pay for four or five streaming
services anymore
so
that is another reason but a big reason
is the amount of money they've spent on
this damn project you know it's it's I
mean they did I think this does hold the
record of any broadcast cable I mean
this is It's it wins all the rep all the
trophies and that in that
but another thing that um
Amazon has done and you've been watching
the Sandman I guess
I lost watched the last episode last
night I watched the bonus episode last
night so I mean there's a crapload of
money they spent there too yep you know
and
some of the money that like Apple TV is
spending is a stock astonishing yeah
uh 30 million dollars an episode on The
Last Airbender and that's a hell of a
thing considering Last Airbender was a
brilliant cartoon a terrible movie that
bombed and lost everybody a lot of money
and now they're spending a lot of money
on a live action series that is brave
that is and look what you know the
Cowboy Bebop I don't know if you saw
that but yeah I watched the first two or
three episodes and then I wished I was I
I think I didn't get halfway through the
first it was just
it wasn't the actions it's just the
white or something was way off
uh Harris has just got back from Costa
Rica and he really wanted to be with us
he is stuck in the airport he really
tried to make it he's even wearing his
side track shirt look at that boy he's
advertising this channel wherever he
goes he's a good looking lad so um women
are looking at him at least I might get
a few views from women that'd be good
um
hello ladies Harris is on the channel
next week
but yeah the amount of money
they've spent does concern me because
like I say other projects coming through
but
it's not it's not the end of the world
it's fan man though if we talk about
Sandman briefly
I I wasn't sure about the first episode
I watched your first episode and I was
thinking I'm not sure what they don't
really like the guy they've got play in
the Sandman I don't really like him and
they've got a different actor each week
by the second episode I was like I was
an idiot in the first episode this is
awesome
um and it actually is
buying the third episode I'm there
thinking
if the SEC if this doesn't if they don't
get a second series I mean what the
actual [ __ ] I mean Netflix are just they
make some odd decisions sometimes
they make some good decisions as well
and I think Resident Evil was just a bad
show it doesn't reserve a second series
it wasn't very good
um
all-time favorite graphic novel Watchmen
and Sandman I mean this I've got these
things right
only one
of all of the innocent entire this is
volume one
and here's
volume two
I even got the you know the um
pristine wonderful earthquake
do you know I think I was reaching about
the one of the producers from the
Sandman and they said
um one of the things they were really
careful about when they set the contract
up with Netflix was to make sure that if
Netflix didn't pick up the second season
that they could move
and we're very careful to make sure they
weren't locked in and I I think that's
very Savvy
HBO won't they take all of that you know
Amazon's money then they can move
we'll take your money this season okay
you're you're broke go up to somebody
else oh well I think also they must look
at Netflix's
[Music]
um
Financial records and go just in case
your skins next year just in case we'll
take I think someone else but like I
said there are still some big huge
amounts of money but I do think a lot of
executives are just a little bit nerves
at the moment so it's definitely slowed
things down a little bit
so what do you
hoping for from
the the you know the next 48 hours of
The Lord of the Rings are you for me it
needs to have hooked me by about four or
five episodes in because I at the moment
I'm telling you I'm on the fence
um I thought it was good
but if I'm gonna keep watching it It's
gotta pick up the pace a little bit for
me
50 hours of my life in this it's got to
pick up a little bit
episode four for me episode four we're
good what do you think
I think that the um
you know there was a lot of World
building in the first episode a little
bit more in the second episode but I did
see things were stepping out you know
there was the media there was the
stranger that was a stranger
and if there's anything
that I'd like to see kind of uh
the next 28 hours of this would be one
of the blue Wizards I'd like to there's
so little detail about the blue Wizards
throughout all of tokens for us I mean
it's just oh God answer those questions
it's killing me
yeah
well I like the
uh it looks like we're getting a deeper
dive
into Dwarven culture like in The Hobbit
the dwarves are out in the wilderness
marching toward the missing you know
marching toward the Lonely Mountain
in Lord of the Rings we mostly have a
dwarf
trundling across the Wilderness and then
when we see dwarves in their Mountain
Fortress well they're all dead then we
get Orcs And dialogues
yeah so I think we should call them
dwarves I think we should call them um
vertically challenged
um you know a bit PC as as a shorter
person myself
um you know I think the wolf is a bit
harsh but um so yes vertically
challenged
um
but but yeah no I'm with you on that
yeah we don't actually get to see much
of the culture of that do we we get I
think there's a lot of the Elven culture
though as well that we get to see a bit
more in the how did they get to that
point because obviously by the Lord of
the Rings really they're leaving
um they're they're going back to their
home sort of thing yeah yeah so it's in
Sea
how that will work going forwards and
and and I just think there's
the people that really love Tolkien are
the ones who think if they get an answer
on the blue wizard like you say they'll
just go well it's not talking anyway
so it's not an answer anyway because not
talking
but I just think
the people that are purists read the
books don't watch it so because it's
always going to annoy you but in TV show
but those people
also moaned when Lord of the Rings came
out because of the things that um he
changed and they really didn't like some
of them really didn't like part of The
Hobbit
because he added bits you know
um
so I mean they're just it's just a very
angry people but when I put a video out
I'd put a couple of videos out it's
basically saying calm the [ __ ] down
I've never had more hate
I've never had more hate on this channel
than from Tolkien fans ever
fans the expanse fans get really angry I
put a video out basically saying that
there was a rumor that they were going
to make series seven even though in the
video I say repeatedly this is a rumor
and it's a rumor I don't actually
believe but
um I was told it in good faith so I will
tell you in good faith and but like so
repeatedly rumor
don't actually believe it it could
happen but I doubt it
um and I just got I've got loads of [ __ ]
for that
um and like I'm missing the point of
what I when I say like the third word I
said in the video is rumor and that
excuse me got me going
um but yeah but um the tolconists though
the real hardcore fans they love this
and I I don't mind the passion I love
the passion
um I get just as angry about Stargate
and Star Trek when people slag things
off and I'm just like you know
even before they shot the first
frame of Fellowship of the Ring
there's all these bands
that were just really
kind of ugly and bullying towards you
know Elijah Wood especially live Tyler I
mean they were taking all of their
lived in Anger from who lives Tyler's
dad is to her
thank God did she do a great job she's
she's fantastic I mean uh Elijah Wood
did a great job
pretty much
yeah yeah Martin Freeman's career was on
a real you know a very steep directory
and I would say doing The Hobbit gave it
a gave it a bit of a hit yeah I think
I'll be wrong he's still in the Marvel
movies and whatever but he's come back
to the BBC name
um it's not in his career great but I
agree with you fantastic job Elijah
Woods though really Korea yeah
it's it's not really gone anywhere since
is it but that's maybe it maybe he just
sometimes you get these iconic
characters and these iconic things you
know you've got to be a hell of an actor
to drug out of it you know like like um
uh Radcliffe with
um you know after Harry Potter luckily
he's an amazing actor and he's have you
seen the advert for weird alkovic
that is a weird alcovich
he did a um
I think it was on Hulu with um
uh forget what it was it was about oh
God who was it Sandy Sandra Bullock
and he was like this evil billionaire is
wanting this treasure and she was a
romance um
lost treasure or something
it's just a really is this a good actor
it's just a really good actor and but he
was sensible he went he after after
Harry Potter he went back to the theater
and he learned you know and he
got naked in that in that that horse he
plated
he learned his craft he must have had so
many movie Parts but he went no I want
to go and learn my craft and he was hurt
at the time he was drinking a lot and
you know and he was having a few bombs
but I mean um but he learned his craft
and he's come back and oh my god he's a
good actor that thing he did a movie
um
he got lost in the jungle and it's based
on a true story and I forget what it's
called but it was on I think it was on
Amazon
um and by the end of it he'd lost like
two Stone by the end of it because he's
you know he he's that committed to the
role sort of thing and again it's one of
those part all the way through you go
into just you're just in all of him and
it's only a matter of time until he gets
the right part to win or cards like
Weird Al
which is obviously I've seen the advert
it's not remotely true any of it it's
all [ __ ] it's like him like him in
an affair with Madonna and him being you
know it's a definitely a Weird Al movie
um but I just it's it's the untold true
story in that it's Untold because it's
not true
um but I can't wait and I just I've I've
been listening to a lot of polka this
week
on every album we now will do
um this polka Montage of like songs that
are popular that year so it's all these
like really heavy rock songs but polka
this is like I love it I freaking great
um but anyway that's going off off
topics in terms of Elijah Wood I mean he
did a lot of quirky stuff after a little
Rings like he did Wilford
yeah and I also um
his voice he was a voice of Star Wars
resistance
holistic detective agency he was also in
there that was awful that the British
version was much better the American
version was terrible but one thing he's
mostly been doing now he's got a
production company for
um
not not slasher type of horror movies he
wants to go back to like emotional
horror stories and he's there like
almost 20 credits
because he took his Lord of the Rings
money and just started a horror
production company
I love that doing something he loves I
love that
right so we'll get back to it because
we're going to call it in an evening it
was called the lost city thank you very
much for the character dashboard man and
um
the other fella in it that was in all
the dancing videos the stripper videos I
forgotten his [ __ ] name I love him
he's one of those great actors and he's
the he's the other character in it
they're not the Brad Pitt one the other
one what's his name
uh
um he was he was up for the part of John
Carter you know the John Carter movie
that absolutely won
he was desperate to do it and they gave
it to the fella and excuse me I'll just
get his name in one second Channing
Tatum Channing Tatum was absolutely do
it and they gave it to the other fella
and the movie bombed and I think if
they'd have given it Channing Tatum I
don't think that movie would have bombed
quite so much
and she 100 would have gone to watch it
um because my mom is a she watches all
the Marvel movies and it's not because
she likes Marvel movies because I keep
telling her Chris Hemsworth isn't it
um so and he gets a top off and she's
like oh yeah horrible doubt as I am
um I think there is a definitely fatigue
but I also think Marvel is shooting
themselves in the foot
because they're having quality over
quantity no the other way around
quantity over quality
yeah
the CGI is so dodgy in the last couple
of projects you know it's I did watch
other things this week you know I'm now
on
um since we last spoke I think I've
watched seven or eight uh seasons of
Stargate sg1 I'm on seasons
dude covet is driving I am so bored
I'll do a video a day with you God if if
you like didn't have a job
but you know so uh I just watched the
the 200th episode The 200th episode of
SG-1 you know we're gonna have all these
crazy you know it's just a Clips episode
I hated that when it came out I
laughed out loud at one part you know uh
Vala is pitching all these crazy ideas
and it's like you know when you think
about oh yeah that's the Wizard of Oz it
oh yeah that's termitive you know and
then you know they show these clips of
all the the um
the SG-1 characters you know in uh oh
God what was that uh
what was that the Muppet sci-fi show
with Ben Browder and Claudia Black
um it was um well police were they were
taking the piss out of wasn't it
or Farscape oh sorry I'm with you I'm
sorry I'm with you
and so then all the characters are great
stuff in these crazy far escaping kind
of characters you know then Marty goes
you know after the clip Marta goes I
don't even know what that was
York
um but no I am with you um I think
She-Hulk is
quite bad
um
supposed to be a comedy I get that the
comic book is supposed to be completely
Deadpool of you know all of that they
can't keep doing the same thing at the
end of the day they can't they can't
keep doing the same things they're
trying to do different things right
um you know they're doing Horrors and
they're doing all sorts but I just I'm
not so sure about She-Hulk but I think
they were always going to struggle with
She-Hulk you're either take fun of it
and poke fun or you just don't make it
and I think that was the thing but I am
struggling a little bit but I I tell you
what the Hawkeye series was actually
Lowe's better than I thought it was
going to be and you know what the uh
what was that Winter Soldier and the
Patriot was it well I found that a
little boring I thought it was a great
it was a a buddy cop movie
yeah
on the whole I wasn't a big fan the two
characters their interaction yeah you
know uh the new Captain America and uh
I I kind of like the writing in it but
you know the
they doesn't stand up you know when
these um
short series that they're doing
it doesn't stand up to the quality of
Loki
No One Division
because one division in both look you're
like you're sitting there like
what the hell is going on and you do
that first episode two yeah very much
when we get to episode three oh my God
it's this and this and oh my God this
points to this and then there's the
other thing and oh my God I can't stand
it
and then you watch it one division was a
slow burner let's be honest it was a
freaking slow burn but listen right
we have to call it in the evening
because we're at the hour mark and
you've pushed it little thing and I I
will be honest as always at this point
in these videos and either way
so on the Lord of the Rings just to just
to end that whole conversation and draw
the circle because it's a ring and
there's a massive one behind me right
right right we enjoyed it
there's a lot for her to go and a lot of
these YouTube videos they're full of
[ __ ] because I've got an agenda done
excellent
[Laughter]
stormy even though you are very poorly
and you know you haven't got your normal
speakers and everything thank you so
much for joining me
um
next week we will be back and we will be
back with Harris
and I actually have to go to the toilet
so okay you want me to say goodbye
say goodbye bye-bye
I hope you feel better
bye bye everybody go pee